when you have the federal reserve you
have something that's like not auditable
right it's a monetary system that is
completely opaque to everybody it
doesn't really even have legislation
they just sort of do whatever they want
with bitcoin you have the ability to
actually go audit the stuff yourself and
this is what i'm teaching to my students
jimmy song is an author podcaster
computer programmer and contributor to
what is known as bitcoin core which is
an open source project for researching
testing and upgrading the software that
people all over the world use to connect
to this decentralized monetary network
song also runs two-day seminars training
coders to work in the bitcoin industry
can you guys look into the matrix yet do
you recognize what's in the script sig
back in
when i was learning it i was very
frustrated with the resources that were
out there and it took me days to learn
something that really should have taken
me like half an hour at the most
it's just that like no one was there to
help me and on the other side when i was
hiring at different companies that i was
at it was hard to find people
that actually knew this stuff so i i
knew that there was a need at both ends
and part of why i started it was because
i knew i could do a better job than what
the market was already doing this is the
big asymmetry that we use
for public key cryptography programming
blockchain is a 16-hour seminar
consisting of lectures and hands-on
exercises song has also taught the same
material over the course of an entire
semester at the university of texas at
austin when i was teaching that that one
semester i had some pretty brilliant
students these were grad students in
electrical engineering computer science
and business and the thing is like their
their motivations are not necessarily
the same as the students that i get when
i teach my two day seminars so
they care very much about their grade
and making sure that you know they they
are not necessarily learning but getting
the right credential whereas the people
that are coming to my seminars they're
paying me money
but they are motivated to go and learn
the actual protocols there's not really
in bitcoin like an uh a university
degree or a qualification and i think
the book on water in general is
skeptical of those kind of things anyway
song has been teaching students all over
the world for more than four years
including rajal walsh a former new
zealander police officer who took the
seminar in australia in 2018. but i
think jimmy's course is about as close
as you get to that where people know his
reputation he's about the best guy
that's actively teaching and he's got a
reproducible system
for passing this information on out of
anyone out there i would love to slay
the educational leviathan definitely um
but yeah i mean the market's kind of
going that way because it's proving
itself and there are lots of different
platforms where you can self-learn and
for companies hiring one of the best
signals that you can get is people that
are learning on their own it's like it's
a better signal than what college they
came out of walsh discovered bitcoin
when he read about the silk road a dark
web e-commerce site that allowed users
to buy drugs or pretty much anything
else using the cryptocurrency anyone
could log on and buy almost anything you
can imagine and have it sent out through
someone else and you could all connect
through these decentralized systems
which were you know untraceable or very
very private and anonymous
and to me that just blew my mind that
this had been operating for over two
years run the noses of you know american
law enforcement
agencies and there wasn't anything they
could do about it the silk road not only
established that it was possible to take
violence out of the drug trade by
allowing buyers and sellers to transact
online it also demonstrated that bitcoin
lived up to its promise of being
uncensorable money and that no credit
card company bank or government could
obstruct people from using it to pay for
things and i just don't think most
people really kind of comprehended just
how big of a deal that was and of course
you know you learned about the coin
through that process because that's the
financial medium that facilitated all
this to go on in 2018 walsh attended the
building on bitcoin conference and
observed that even people without
extensive programming experience were
making important contributions to
bitcoin and these guys were just two
regular coders you know competent coders
but not some super computer geniuses who
just saw a problem and they decided well
i'm just going to fix this and to me it
just blew my mind about the agency that
you have in this space because it's open
source and up to anyone
so i kind of came back and and just
decided okay
code is where it is walsh was inspired
to apply for jimmy song's course though
he didn't have the prerequisite
programming experience so he first
enrolled in some online bootcamps and
took a free class from one of song's
former students so three months ago i
knew nothing about coding and here's me
applying for for jimmy's course today
walsh works at swan bitcoin an exchange
that also considers educating new users
to be central to its mission just over
three years after knowing nothing about
programming here i am working more or
less a dream job over 500 people have
contributed to the bitcoin core software
since the project started and anyone can
participate in the process of submitting
and reviewing new code no matter who
they are where they live or what degrees
they hold since bitcoin is open source
software the rules governing how it
functions are also fully transparent
walsh and song say that this spirit of
radical transparency and emphasis on
demonstrated skill over credentialism
are essential to what they love about
bitcoin anyone can create anything all
the code and all the information you
need is there for free online anyone
anywhere in the world can read that and
participate you're not going to be able
to audit the fed but you can audit the
bitcoin blockchain and many nodes do
right if you're running your own
software you don't have to trust anyone
because the software checks that the
ledger balances and everything is good
and to really understand that you have
to examine the code like line by line
and so on and i i try to help with that
with my seminar and it's not necessarily
easy but it can be done and it's
possible and and that that makes all the
difference in the world to hear more
about jimmy song's seminars and about
his new book thank god for bitcoin
reason caught up with him in october at
the 2021 oslo freedom forum which
brought together the human rights
community with the bitcoin community for
a two-day conference in miami we talked
about the morality of money his disdain
for traditional education and the ways
in which he thinks bitcoin complements
christian theology
[Music]
i want to get into some detail about the
seminars but before we do that i want to
talk a little bit about like fiat
education
what you've referred to as and you
taught at ut for a semester basically
what has become a two-day seminar you
talk about
the education system and what what your
experience has told you about it
yeah so
i mean i i think i've always been like
frustrated with the education system
even as a student
so my teachers in high school hated me
because i would like fall asleep in
class and you know they would wake me up
and like tell me like and i'd answer the
question because i had bread ahead or
whatever but i i was always kind of
frustrated because in a sense uh the
current education system is you just go
at the pace of the slowest learner in
the classroom and it's just not a great
environment right and um in addition
like a lot of the students aren't
necessarily motivated and so on so when
i was teaching that at that one semester
i had some pretty brilliant students
these were grad students in electrical
engineering computer science and
business so you know business school
grad school and the thing is like their
their motivations are not necessarily
the same as the students that i get when
i teach my two day seminars uh so
they care very much about their grade
and making sure that you know they they
are
not necessarily learning but getting the
right credential whereas the people that
are coming to my seminars they're paying
me money but they are motivated to go
learn the actual protocol right like the
the
the thing so they'll ask different types
of questions and they're uh more
concerned about understanding something
versus
maybe getting a grade and these are some
of the best best of the best right like
uh they're they're grad students at
university of texas and you know like
they they understand things very well so
you know the the
contrast for me is uh you know like
if you have sort of like intrinsic
motivation it is so much easier to teach
as a teacher right because if if you're
trying to teach people that don't want
to learn
uh
like it it's it's like pulling teeth it
is very difficult but if you're teaching
people
that want to learn that
like have motivation to go get it
because of financial reasons or whatever
and there's lots of reasons why people
want to learn but um you know they they
are much more motivated to ask you
questions to figure things out and
to really study uh and to get it rather
than hey i'm just in this class like the
current model is very much based on like
sort of like forced education almost
it's not voluntary right that makes
sense yeah yeah and so the students that
you get at your two day seminars now i
mean
they're probably highly motivated highly
interested and it seems like you
probably take the best of the best i
know there's like a base level of skill
that you need to have before you can be
accepted into this seminar just tell me
a little bit more about the students you
get
um the students you accept and
what you're
stuffing into their brains in two days
yeah so there are prerequisites like the
ability to code for example you need to
learn how to code because there it's
like very
interactive and you need to uh
you need to be coding a lot of the time
and i've designed my class that way so
that you you don't just get lectured at
you actually have to code the things
that i just lectured so uh and you know
like you don't
as a coder you you realize you don't
really understand something when you're
forced to code it and it's like okay now
now i have to really understand this uh
so that that's the way the class is
designed so you know that's a
prerequisite and i make sure that people
know how to code before they come to the
class um the motivations uh vary uh so
certainly there are people that you
would expect
maybe programmers that want to get into
this industry um they see that it's
growing and they they have sort of like
personal interests so hey let's align
these let's uh let's get a job in this
industry and so on uh but there are also
lots of other people that take it for
like reasons i would never have expected
so you know i had an accountant take it
uh for for example and he's like i
haven't coded since college but i really
need to understand the protocol so i can
give good tax advice i'm like really
that's not something i expected i've had
uh you know like uh you know angel
investors take it uh because they're
like well i i need to understand this so
that i can understand my investments a
little better and i can uh you know vet
the people that i am
uh uh you know i'm talking to in in a
more intelligent way and so on so
um
yeah i uh ultimately what what ends up
happening is that you get a group of
people that are motivated by different
things and because they're motivated and
because they're together there's
something powerful that goes on in a
classroom when you have
a lot of people that really want to um
learn together and you know they they
have motivation i think this is large
like in places like uh business school
or something like that you get a similar
dynamic where people actually want to be
there so and they're motivated to learn
it it changes the dynamics significantly
versus something like primary education
which is like uh let's like babysit
these kids for 12 hours or something
like that right i think one of the
overarching themes in the whole bitcoin
space is very much being independent
being self-directed and figuring things
out on your own you know taking the
initiative to say this is something i
want to know how to do or something that
i want to know about and therefore the
responsibility is i'm going to put the
responsibility on myself to go figure it
out but you know at the same time one
issue with bitcoin right now
um that i've seen in many places from
people who are sympathetic to bitcoin
and are sympathetic to its purpose
but you know there's some relatively
intimidating intimidating barriers to
entry even right now though it's gotten
a lot better
but i mean how temporary is that problem
in your opinion and i mean can there be
any real substitute to just like
figuring it out for yourself yeah i i i
the question is very interesting because
uh you know it is this balance between
um sort of like
liberty and responsibility so anytime
you have freedom there's uh sort of like
a responsibility that you have to take
for yourself and this is all a part of
self-sovereignty it it makes no sense
to just have liberty by itself because
you have to sort of like take care of
the consequences on your own as well um
and bitcoin definitely has a significant
amount of that where
um you know we're we're not naturally
used to sort of taking responsibility
for our own
wealth uh and you know we're used to
sort of like outsourcing it to banks or
other people that sort of keep it secure
for us so for a lot of people
um this induces a lot of stress because
they're like well what if i lose this i
can you know lose a ton of money and
this is this is not something that
they're used to i think uh you know
people like say during the gold standard
and and
prior to that you know they they had
this sense of responsibility that they
grew up with but we pretty much removed
it everywhere so it's it's very
difficult for them to
kind of understand that and uh and get
used to it but it is something that i
think uh
you know at least in the bitcoin
community
it it it needs to be emphasized because
if it's not self-sovereign then you're
trusting somebody else in which case it
gets centralized and so on uh
but you know like to your point like uh
it is a technology and i do think it's
going to get better if you ask people in
1985 like is everyone gonna use a
computer they would be like you're crazy
no no one's gonna use it like this too
hard to use you have to like understand
command line commands and
you know random things like that of
course you know graphical user
interfaces
they made it much much easier by making
it more user friendly
but it's still a complicated machine
that can do lots of different things um
i i think bitcoin will uh sort of go in
the same direction as more entrepreneurs
come in and
um you know
bring
uh
different goods and services that will
help
the community or you know help more
people on board right so with that you
were talking about the gold standard a
little bit so let's go
back in time
and
you know
one of the reasons why why people are
not used to taking care of their wealth
is because
i mean
it was
really difficult that's like practically
for basically ever um and you know and
with that one of the things that people
say about bitcoin is that it's a model t
of cryptocurrency
but you know
is it gold that was a model t of
currency or like you know let's is that
is that
a fair way to put it i mean what are the
problems
with gold that maybe fiat tried to solve
in some sense but now bitcoin is coming
along and maybe attempting to solve
both of those problems while keeping the
advantages of each as well
yeah um so i would say the big problem
with gold
is
its physicality the fact that it has a
physical location that makes it very
difficult to secure you either have to
have
uh you know a giant security system
around the physical object so you need
like a vault maybe like armed guards or
something like that which is what a bank
does um
or you need to like uh you know trust
somebody else with it right like you can
have it yourself and secure it yourself
which is very difficult with a physical
object because you know there's violence
basically available um
or you can trust it to somebody else
that will do a lot of the same things
but in a centralized way um and if you
study sort of like the evolution of
money uh especially you know the
transition from gold to fiat you know
like ending pretty much in 1971
yeah it started as uh you know people
wanting to secure their goal because
they they wanted to sort of outsource
that responsibility because securing
goal physically was so difficult um and
then it went to basically these places
that you know held the goal for you
which we call banks and that
centralization eventually led to you
know fractional reserve banking um which
in turn led to central banks which in
turn led to
uh the abolishment of the gold standard
so
the the lack of security ultimate or the
lack of secure ability let's let's put
it that way um ultimately led to
fiat money and this is something that we
pointed out in in our book uh thank god
for bitcoin that
you know there there is this sort of
like slow descent into
you know
less and less sound money that happens
because of its physicality with bitcoin
because it doesn't have a physical
location
it is uh it can be uh unconfiscatable so
you you can make it so that
uh you know only you have access to that
coin and uh you know you don't you don't
need arm guards and motion detection
systems and steel doors and all this
other stuff that banks have for to
secure physical stuff um you have
something digital which means that you
know you can kind of keep it in your
mind and if you don't have to give it up
if you don't want to it's uh it's i
think what
vijay boyapatti calls like a super
property right uh it's a property right
that we've never
been able to have that
uh before with any physical commodity
because it can be seized
there's
the lack of seizability that that's
that's something brand new that we've
never had before
so your podcast is called bitcoin fixes
this
and we're gonna get to your book but one
one of the chapters in your book is
what bitcoin can't fix
so
let's let's talk about that what can't
bitcoin fix
uh well i i don't think it can fix the
human heart right like uh there are evil
people in the world um and if you're a
christian you believe that we
you everyone has some level of evil in
them and it's it's a
matter of sort of like
you know surrendering yourself to god so
that that that evil can be fixed
to some extent
um
but that that's something that i i don't
think can be fixed it doesn't suddenly
make people good um there there are lots
of evil people in the world and uh it
doesn't make your heart good uh so i
would say
uh to answer it more succinctly it
doesn't fix character it doesn't fix um
you know just
what what what you are on the inside um
it does sort of like change the
incentive so that
it doesn't punish goodness and reward
evil right like which the current fiat
system does uh instead it goes the other
way where it rewards like doing stuff
like saving money
for the future uh and uh punishing
things like you know like
fomo spending and things like that that
leads us into your book one of the first
sentences in your book is that money is
deeply spiritual and i think for many
people religious or not that probably
sounds
kind of absurd and maybe for the
religious people maybe even like
bordering on some kind of blasphemy
you know i think the general assumption
about money is that it's worldly and
materialistic and while it's important
to our lives
that may be just a
unfortunate symptom
of how
you know the market strips us of our
humanity and forces us to care about
these material things rather than
focusing on
you know
helping other people or developing a
spiritual connection to god explain more
why do you say that money is deeply
spiritual yeah uh so money is really
um
it is spiritual because first of all
money doesn't exist without people right
like you you remove people from the
equation
money does not exist uh
it's uh if you think of it sort of like
in a mathematical way um which i do
because i was a math major you can think
of
uh
you know the civilization as a network
of relationships each person is a node
and each connection uh or each edge is
the relationship between people and
those relationships are significantly
affected by money right like it's a it's
actually kind of a way to
figure out the balance between people
right and this by the way is interesting
because it's uh
mapped very well by the lightning
network which we can get to um but
that that relationship between people is
um
it can be
uh
enhanced in to a large degree with money
because
if you are with a stranger you you don't
necessarily want to interact with them
because you don't know like you know
what uh you know how you can uh relate
to them and so on uh but if there exists
sort of like this common money well now
now you can trade with them you can you
can relate to people through through
that and of course it's uh it's a big
part of like the stress of a lot of
relationships a lot of divorces happen
because of money problems and
um you know i mean money money is just
the reality and
if you read if you're a christian you
know like think about you know what
salvation is described as in the bible
right it's
debt
payment forgiveness redemption these are
all monetary terms right and and they're
they're there because they give us sort
of like an uh and insight into
our relationship with god
and our relationship with each other it
has uh you know this monetary component
which
we can use to understand um and you know
interact with the rest of civilization
so it it it has a very deep place in
human relationships and it is therefore
very much very spiritual so
it's a way you're saying that not money
is not this materialistic worldly
concern it's actually
a method by which we can relate to and
and develop
relationships with people who we
otherwise would have not been able to do
so yeah oh well and and relationships
that we already have um you know like
a lot of uh
sort of taxes occur in that right like
because you know when you die you have
that state estate tax but that's like a
relationship between you and the people
that you've already known um there's a
lot of uh monetary
um
sort of
well no let me put it this way
every relationship has
some
form of monetary component in it whether
you recognize it or not um and you know
like it might not be as important in
certain relationships and so on but
there you know it's undeniable that
money represents sort of like your labor
or the value that you provided others
and
as a result you know we we trust in the
money to
along each edge of every relationship to
represent that and if you are
transferring value to another person
essentially you're participating in this
network of nodes which we call
civilization and
that that's how the free market is
supposed to work with money it's it's
this
thing that gets transferred across every
edge in this giant graph of human
relationships um
so of course like it's it's deeply
impactful and matters deeply for
everything and to just sort of call it
worldly and say it doesn't matter um i i
don't i think kind of misses the point
because
even in our relationship with god you
know there there is this monetary
metaphor probably because there's
something deeply um
significant about value transfer within
relationships
you know some people just claim that
money is
neutral it's just a neutral tool that we
use
it's neither good nor evil but you you
all
make the
make a different claim in the book that
it is it can actually be money
itself can be
good or evil and it doesn't matter
necessarily how you use it it starts
more with the money you could can you
expand upon that you know why is it
different from like a hammer or a gun or
these other tools that probably they do
seem much more neutral
well
i i i i would even question that okay
but but to to a degree i uh you know
first of all this is not an argument
that is original to us i i think we have
like uh jan guido hulsman who uh wrote
the ethics of money production and gary
north who wrote honest money they made
these arguments before
the monetary system can be good or evil
depending on the incentives that it
produces so the incentives that the fiat
monetary system produces are very much
towards you know essentially theft um
especially by government i call it
i call inflation a tax that has
uh you know that is implicit uh has no
transparency no
legislation or even consent by uh any of
the governed and it ends up becoming
this uh pernicious force uh for that uh
and we know theft is wrong right
that's the very
property rights are very basic and i
think uh most people can understand that
so
um you know if it if a monetary system
incentivizes theft which
you know the central bank back fiat
monetary system definitely does
then i think it's very much
evil right like if uh
if if
if there was sort of like a system that
incentivizes you to um
do something evil you i i think you can
call the system itself evil so
uh you know uh like
i don't know like the nazis for example
i i don't
jump straight to the knives straight to
the nazis right like they they
uh you know if they incentivize some
particular evil thing and they certainly
did by persecution of jews or whatever i
think you can call that system evil um
and the monetary system is as gargantuan
as certainly as uh you know a
whole world view like nazism or
stalinism or many and many other things
um so it's not
so much a tool as it is a system and uh
you know
depending on uh the actual system i
think you have to evaluate it based on
the incentives that it does and
at least for money um
you know there there's definitely a
tendency towards theft that
that you don't see in something like you
know a hard gold standard where you
actually have to carry around gold i
mean you could steal but it takes a lot
more effort it's it's
it's very costly with with uh uh with
central bank back fiat
money it's literally like a press of a
button and you know you you have six
trillion extra dollars it's it's kind of
insane so you so you're saying that the
because bitcoin as a system
ins
helps human beings um
avoid things they would otherwise be
tempted to do bad things that they'd be
otherwise tempted to do that makes
bitcoin
good yeah i would say so um and that
like if it incentivizes the
good things
and disincentivizes bad things i would
say that the system itself is morally
superior to something that does the
opposite yeah and what's interesting
about that too is that bitcoin
it actually doesn't matter like your
opinion about what's good or evil or my
opinion or anyone else's opinion bitcoin
doesn't know that all it does
is incentivize human beings to behave in
certain ways according to maybe their
their natural
state you know
so but you know that's kind of you know
some people might say that's a little
bit at odds with
how bitcoin
has a reputation
false or not of being used by criminals
and
you know
albeit cash has it's used by criminals
as well but that could just be a
result of
how the us dollar is much more popular
um what do you say to that
yeah so i certainly it can be used for
evil purposes i don't think like like i
mentioned earlier it doesn't change the
human heart right if if you
want to do something evil
bitcoin's not suddenly going to stop you
um and this is sort of like the
mentality shift that you have to have
that that's kind of what the fiat
monetary system or at least uh it it
tries to do or it claims to try to do
is prevent people from doing evil right
like if you
are um
you know uh
if you're trying to open a business as a
marijuana dispensary in colorado that's
something that the fiat banking system
doesn't let you
do because they won't let you open a
bank account with um uh you know because
of federal
mandates and so on so that's a way to
sort of like quote unquote prevent evil
i i don't think in my view i think that
tends to overstep the rights of
everybody else um and you know
of course there's gonna be people that
are trying to do evil if you quote
unquote try to prevent evil it tends to
first of all not prevent the evil and
second infringe on the rights of
everybody else so there's that way to do
it which it tends to be extremely
centralized or there's the other way to
do it which is allow for it and then
pers uh prosecute them afterwards i mean
if if you are doing money laundering or
ransomware or or whatever
well i mean they're doing evil i think
uh as as a society we recognize when
people's rights are being violated um in
some way shape or form but if they are
being violated then yeah go go prosecute
them i i think that's a perfectly
reasonable thing to do
but to like sort of say well you're not
allowed to do this because you might do
x
that that i think is a very
um
i don't know
i i don't think that way works and i i
don't think that way is just either
another thing you guys talk about in the
book is how
bad money like fiat money
incentivizes a love of money and
well the first thing is like a casual
observer might look at uh bitcoiners
talking about loving money and they're
like you guys are obsessed with bitcoin
you love money but what do you what do
you mean but bad money
incentivizes love of money and what's
wrong with money i mean after all money
is deeply spiritual yeah yeah and and i
i agree that uh you know
there is uh uh
like money is a gift right like in in
that sense it's uh it's very useful it
it can keep sort of like an account of
how much value you've provided to others
and have that paid back to you later and
so on but uh but money uh like
at least in a central bank back fiat
monetary system
tends to
um
get people obsessed with it and the
reason is obvious it's uh well not
necessarily obvious but
it it's uh it's because of inflation you
you have continuous monetary expansion
which means that in order to keep up you
are more or less forced to invest
um so i i joked that you have to make
your money twice once when you earn it
and second time to keep it because if
you want to keep your money well now you
have to go into real estate and stocks
and all this other stuff
because otherwise it will be debased
away so like m2 in 1959 was like 289
billion dollars it's now currently like
20 something trillion um it's expanded
at like seven percent right like if you
measure it that way rather than the cpi
which always magically comes in at like
two or three percent
so it's been expanding at a tremendous
rate for a very long time so you're
forced to think about how to keep it so
that that that uh takes away a lot of
the energy and time from a lot of some
of the most productive people in the
world so they they're always con if you
know anybody rich that's what they're
concerned about okay how do i keep this
money what investments do i put it in
how do i make sure that this this is
going there and whatever
um and that that causes this obsession
with investments and so on so that's one
aspect in which you get obsessed with
money the other aspect
is
like if you're living paycheck to
paycheck especially you you are obsessed
with money because you can't really save
right like you you there there is no
sort of like uh buffer right this is on
the other end you got the ultra rich
side who are completely obsessed with
investments they're putting time money
and energy into things that really
aren't benefiting anybody else they're
not creating goods or services which
would benefit civilization instead they
are obsessed with
um
you know making uh you know seven
percent every year just to keep up with
inflation on the other hand you got
people that are you know like living
paycheck to paycheck that can't save
because there's no savings vehicle so
that means that they don't have a buffer
so they're constantly like in this debt
cycle and they have to be obsessed with
money because otherwise they can't live
so
either way it you know this whole system
essentially makes it so that you end up
absolutely obsessed with money that is
what you think about day and night
whereas for bitcoiners
and you pointed this out uh you know we
are obsessed with bitcoin and especially
bitcoin adoption
because we think this will reduce both
of those things
if you do have the ability to save
well then you don't have to care so much
about investments you can actually
you know work a little harder now and
then relax a little more later instead
of just going and getting into this debt
cycle where you're essentially enslaved
to the bank or credit cards or whatever
uh or your job or whatever so it it ends
up being a much better
uh
you know system because it frees
people's minds and thoughts to actually
provide goods and services for others so
this book thank god for bitcoin is an
outgrowth from a
bible study group where you guys wanted
to investigate money and it kind of grew
from there and i think that's your
target audience i think you've said that
that's exactly who you want to target
like this thank god for bitcoin it
should end up in your bible study group
i think that's basically your position
on the book and one of the things you
all talk about in the book is that
money as a subject kind of strikes fear
and awkwardness into the hearts of
christians and
why do you think that is yeah a lot of
it is because of the stuff that we
talked about
like if you already have money then
you're concerned with keeping it and if
you don't have it then you're concerned
with debt and like making sure you get
out of it and so on um and again this is
part of the obsession that is sort of
induced by the fiat monetary system and
that anxiety and uh you know fear that
people feel it's uh it's not really
kosher to talk about in in almost any
setting and uh you know we're not really
taught about it i like it took me you
know i i went to high school and college
and everything i was never taught about
how the fiat central bank back fiat
monetary system works that you know
nearly every loan in the economy is
ex-nihilo and
all that stuff like no one really
understands it so we're we're not taught
about it we're not
uh educated and um we we don't
understand what it's for we just like
sort of are
bombarded with the immediate uh
sort of needs of of the money that we
have or the debt that we service and
that that becomes sort of like the thing
that we have to serve instead
of you know other things and that that's
yeah it gets to be
sort of an obsession and
for a lot of people it it's uh it's
definitely not healthy but yeah and to
to get back to your question why don't
people want to talk about it
particularly christians yeah i mean
there seems to be almost like
it's not universal for sure but there's
i i've seen it a lot in my own
experience where there seems to be kind
of a default skepticism or maybe even
hostility towards like markets and maybe
they're just using buzzwords but i mean
i think that's kind of what i'm what i'm
getting at a little bit right because uh
they they should be rightfully at least
suspicious of you know the obsession
with investments and obsession with like
uh debt and things like that
there's definitely uh like
something correct about that
um but i would say that a lot of that is
induced by the fiat monetary system and
like getting into the correct view of
money which is it's supposed to serve
you right like it's interesting when you
think about
the fiat monetary system it's all based
on debt so all money is dead and you uh
the the people that get the lowest
interest rates tend to be the richest
and the highest interest rates tend to
be the poorest
the the degree to which you're uh
you have to pay attention to it is the
degree to which you're in debt and uh
even very rich people are in tons of
debt because that's how they can make
more wealth on their money and so on um
poor people are certainly in a lot of
debt it forces you to be obsessed with
it right like we as a question what you
would call like serving money it's
literally servicing that right like it's
like there there is the bank that gives
you a loan of some kind whether it's a
mortgage credit card or whatever you are
servicing that
rather than servicing god and that that
to me is uh at the heart of
uh you know why
you know people are so low to talk about
it because they they recognize that like
their actions are very much um
you know serving the this monetary god
um instead
of
you know the the god that they uh
purport to serve and yeah i i think
jesus made it very clear you can't both
serve both money and god so you have to
choose one or the other if you're in
debt i think to a large degree you are
forced to serve money your book is
filled with bible passages that kind of
support the points you're making and one
of the things
that struck me is how there
are a lot of stories in the bible about
currency collapse
um you know there was
there was reference to currency collapse
in egypt and um so tell me more about
these biblical accounts and
what do you think christians should be
gleaning from that and
i guess we've kind of touched on this
already but
with all of these references and all of
these passages that you referenced in
the book why has this been so
why is your book like novel in a certain
sense
why is it novel you know yeah yeah so i
i think all of those systems right they
they
uh the and if you study the history of
like currency collapse and things like
that
it's almost always because of essential
control over the currency so
the uh so
uh you know at least uh in roman times
and uh you know the the basement of the
daenerys um you know ended up
causing a lot of problems for the roman
empire and ultimately led to the
collapse of rome
um but that that whole
uh you know every single civilization
that the base is their money ends up
collapsing but the temptation to the
base comes from centralized control over
money itself and of course that's
happened like at an accelerating rate
over the last 150 years or so there's
more and more incidences of
hyperinflation all over the place
because there's a central controller of
the money supply and they will always
be tempted to go steal from everybody
else and they they tend to be the
biggest thieves of all
so that
that in turn means that
uh you know these civilizations uh
end up collapsing because you only need
one bad ruler or one bad government in
order to like trigger that and then once
it's triggered it's sort of a you know
you know snowball going downhill you
know you're not really going to stop it
um
but uh but with bitcoin you have
something that's actually decentralized
you you have no central controller that
and you have
uh it doesn't even have a physical
location so there's no like executive
order 6102 to you know confiscate all
gold so
that means that everyone has this
ability to
possess their own stuff
to be self-sovereign over their own
money um and that lack of centralization
means that you know it it doesn't have
to you know currency doesn't have to
collapse like it always seems to um and
that
that i think is
the better way and i think that's how um
you know will be under a bitcoin
standard as long as people
actually like take responsibility over
their own coins and so on i'm going to
jump back to the seminar a little bit
because something you said reminded me
that i forgot to talk about something
which is
you know you spent all this time in high
school and college and no one ever
taught you how the federal reserve
system works i never talked to how the
monetary system works i suspect that i
suspect that's because they don't
understand it i don't know if anyone
understands it but with bitcoin it
actually is possible to understand it
it's open to anyone who wants to take
the interest
so tell me more about your seminar in
that respect a bit in bitcoin in that
respect as compared to federal reserve
which is operating in secrecy and and
that makes bitcoin like pretty
revolutionary
yeah it's it's transparent right like
that that's kind of what we're talking
about um you know you're not going to be
able to audit the fed but you can audit
the bitcoin blockchain and many nodes do
right if you're running your own
software you don't have to trust anyone
because the software checks that the
ledger balances and everything is good
um and you can go in and learn exactly
how those transactions are structured
how the blocks are structured how the
ledger is designed and everything else
and um how to check for all of that
stuff um and that's key because if you
uh if you have a an organization like
the fed
they have zero transparency i mean they
they release like meeting notes like
once a month like you know that that's
about it you don't you don't really get
to see all right where's the money
actually going who's benefiting from it
um you know who are the owners of it and
we don't know any of that stuff that
that that stuff is just completely
hidden and it sort of like lurks in the
shadows
uh and this is in stark contrast to
bitcoin which is completely open source
you can examine the code yourself you
can go learn every single thing that is
uh you know part of the system and
there's nothing hidden about it
and that in turn means that you have to
really
uh like to really understand that you
have to examine the code like line by
line and so on and i i try to help with
that with my seminar uh and it's not
necessarily easy but it can be done and
it's possible and and that that makes
all the difference in the world whereas
with the federal reserve all the public
information that we have there is very
little chance that you're going to
understand all all of the things that
are going on even people at the fed do
not understand all of the things that
are going on they're just sort of
guessing and saying okay we have this
information and we're gonna you know do
these open market operations and we're
gonna allow these loan facilities and
all this other stuff in order to
save the economy and it's uh it's
keynesian arrogance at the at its worst
yeah so i'm going to close out on this
because one of the things in the book
there's like a couple sentences that was
like the most striking part of the book
for me which is there's a very common
refrain within christian circles
which is you know on faith hope and love
and the greatest of these is love but
let's focus on the hope because you all
talk about how
bitcoin
can provide hope to people in a way that
is new
you know in a certain sense and
so expand upon that and talk like what's
at the end of your book
i think that you you want people to read
it to come away feeling very hopeful
about the future which in a time like
now when things are like so crazy in
bitcoin right now like in the context
like we're at the oslo freedom forum and
there's some hope here and there's
bitcoin is a big presence here talk
about hope especially from the
theological perspective and how it ties
in with with bitcoin and money because i
don't think a lot of christians would
say you know where the hope in the world
is going to come from
an improved monetary system
yeah indeed that's probably not what
they're thinking but i i would argue
that that's true
uh in part because uh well first of all
like uh
if you read like uh you know ethics of
money production or honest money um and
both were written before bitcoin um
uh you know and
you read the ending and it's something
like okay we need to get everybody back
on the gold standard and you know
work towards that and so on and while i
respect that position i just don't think
that's realistic and it it doesn't seem
very hopeful because
when you think about like how the system
works and
how it perpetuates sort of like paying
for votes essentially by bribing the
electorate to vote for your policies
based on uh
you know their perception of what's
happening and so on um that's not gonna
happen uh whereas with something like
bitcoin you can opt out of the entire
system and go to an
entirely new system that's a lot more
fair
um and that i think is hopeful because
it it it gives you sort of like a
prospect for the future that's not
centrally controlled by
some monolithic entity um you know like
the government or the fed or what what
have you uh it gives you sort of like
self-sovereignty it gives you agency it
gives you um the ability to do
uh things that you want to do and not
necessarily you know things that other
people want you to do through sort of
like their forced incentives uh uh
through the monetary system um
theologically hope is um
you know sort of like an understanding
of what's happening and what's going to
happen in the future
and certainly as a christian that that's
something that i am very much
looking forward to uh as
uh you know looking forward to what i am
becoming and what god is making me to be
um in the same way
i think when you look at bitcoin it it
helps you see what society can be what
civilization can be much
in a much better way than the sort of
centralized control sort of
uh
system that we have now where everything
is
controlled by somebody and uh you know
you're you're forced instead of
um you know volunteering to do whatever
uh and it it gives
people a lot more freedom it it helps
people thrive um and it's all based on
this expectation of
um of having uh this freedom in the
future that you might not otherwise have
in in
a centrally controlled uh society like
uh that
we largely have right now that has been
very much proven in the last 18 months